nos idées sont dépendantes des mots
qu'on utilise moins on a de mots pour
s'exprimer moins on adoucit pour penser
avoir du vocabulaire ce n'est pas
seulement pouvoir frimer devant ceux qui
en ont moins c'est d'abord être en
mesure de désigner précisément les
choses moins on a de vocabulaire
disponible moins on est en mesure
d'aller vers l'abstraction et sans
abstraction sans capacité spéculative on
ne peut pas penser le monde moins on
dispose de mots plus le pouvoir est
tranquille
croire que le pouvoir chercherait à
favoriser l'élitisme intellectuel ou
l'élitisme scolaire c'est passé
complètement à côté des mécanismes réels
de la domination des masses à savoir la
décucturation
en appauvrissant la langue on appauvrit
l'esprit critique